alors voilà une meule néolithique le
néolithique ce sont les premiers pays
l'an c'était l'outil utilisé par les
agriculteurs de la préhistoire pour
fabriquer de la farine 1 objets datant
de plus de 6000 ans découverts au maroc
par jean claude klein g j'ai vraiment
notre notre passé quoi de la farine on
en fait toujours aujourd'hui
et l'époque c'était donc les inventeurs
de dupas en fin de compte
passionné d'archéologie jean claude
klein g7 un peu ligne diana jones
yvelinois il possède près de 800 pièces
des silex des lames aiguisées et des
fossiles plusieurs trésors de la
préhistoire découvert lors de recherches
une activité qu'il exerce depuis la fin
des années 70 il saignait de savoir de
connaître l'âge savoir quel type d'homme
la réaliser donc il faut il chercher
dans les livres dans les archives de
quelle période ça peut ça peut être
et après il faut faire le le dessin de
ceux de cet objet et faire un rapport de
prospection un document obligatoire
après une découverte a envoyé à la
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles ou au centre de recherche
archéologique de la région mantaise
jean-claude clergé peut ensuite exposé
ses trouvailles dans sa petite maison en
bois de la boissière école un musée
qu'ils continuent d'alimenter à travers
ces chasses aux trésors